welcome everyone to the daily homeroom I
hope you all had a good weekend I know
or as good as weekend as you could have
given given the circumstances for those
of you all who are new to our daily
homeroom this is really a way for us to
stay connected as we go through this
whole crisis together especially the
secondary crisis I guess you could say
given how many students in the US and
around the world are currently out of
school as we started to see a lot of the
closures happening all of us at Khan
Academy as a not-for-profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere realized
that one the resources that we have
already been working on for many many
years could be really valuable for
teachers students and parents as they're
navigating these closures but we also
realized that it's our duty to do more
to really step up so that you feel as
supported as possible and so starting
with about two or three weeks ago we
started releasing daily schedules and
everything I'm talking about it's all
available at Khan Academy org if you go
to the page you'll see banners and
you'll see a modal show up and you can
go to the various resource pages but we
have things like daily schedules for
different age groups that a lot of
people have found useful that can walk
through how student can structure their
day not just in math but also in reading
and writing the sciences and the
humanities by grade level how could they
can leverage things like Khan Academy
kids for the early learners we are also
on these resources or on our various web
pages putting out webinars that parents
and students and teachers can attend you
can look at the latest on the resources
if you go to Khan Academy but just so
you know we're going to be having
several webinars over the next few days
April 1st 2nd and 3rd we're going to
have a webinar on the first one will be
for young kids aged 2 to 7 this is
really for parents to think about how to
set up a daily schedule then the next
one will be for elementary students ages
2 to 10 and then for middle school
students 11 through 13 and similarly
we're going to have teacher webinars on
those days for elementary students
middle school students and high school
students so we want to do whatever
to support you part of the fun of this
daily homeroom is that we want to make
it as interactive as possible please
over whatever you're using the stream is
whether it's YouTube or Facebook but
we're also monitoring social media on
Instagram and Twitter ask us questions
this is where we're in and try to answer
them and we're also going to try to
bring in special guests over the next
few days and weeks to help answer more
and more of our questions and so with
that I will bring on Dan my colleague
who will help us go through the various
questions and I'll also make one other
announcement I I do this every day I do
remind everyone Khan Academy we are
not-for-profit organization we are
funded by philanthropic donations we
were already running at a deficit before
the crisis and through this crisis our
server usage is about 2.5 of what it
normally is and obviously we're trying
to do more programs and more services so
if you're in a position to do so please
consider donating I do want to give
special thanks to everyone who's donated
over the last several days actually it
just turns out that somebody posted one
of our videos highlighting our need on
reddit yesterday or over the weekend and
that resulted a lot of donations thank
you I want to thank various corporate
partners who've stepped up in really
record time Bank of America was the
first followed closely by 18t google.org
and Novartis all of that makes a huge
difference but I also want to remind
everyone we still need more we're still
running at an accelerated deficit and
and so we want to be able to support you
as much as possible
so with that Dan let's answer some
questions and please ask us anything on
these various whatever you're watching
this on so some today we're gonna try to
do Instagram we're not streaming live on
insta map Ram but we'll try to get it
there this week from Instagram Gregory
Ian asks what is the main thing that
drives you to continue making videos
free for all students oh well you know I
think maybe it's somewhat obvious but
I'll answer the question anyway and to
be clear Khan Academy is much much more
than me now we're over 200 full-time
folks there's thousands of volunteers
around
world who make Khan Academy work and I
think I'm speaking for everyone
including the many thousands actually
tens of thousands of hundreds of
thousands of people who donated to Khan
Academy many of you I think the the the
need to Society of a world where anyone
on the planet is able to tap into their
potential I think it's it's huge if you
look at almost any other problem in
society whether you're talking about
obviously health care is a topic these
days but if you talk about economics if
you talk about safety if you really keep
peeling the onion on one way or the
other it does boil down to education and
if you look at you know access to
education and quality of education and
what people's living conditions are in
the world there's definitely a strong
correlation and they obviously feed into
each other so I personally I can't
imagine I consider myself the luckiest
person on the planet that I get to
devote as many as as much of my energies
as possible to this problem or to the
solution of empowering folks I think
it's just a very very powerful
multiplier you know as famously you can
give people fish but you can also teach
them to fish and that's what education
is really doing so that's what drives me
day in day out there is another I would
say a layer a selfish motivation if you
help which is I love the creation aspect
and I love you know all of these topics
that we cover on Khan Academy are really
beautiful topics and oftentimes I think
students feel like oh I got to go
through this and you know what am I
going to use this but I think there's a
there's a joy that we hope we can bring
to students and teachers and parents to
realize that this is inherently
beautiful subject matter and it's fun to
dive in deep with it so anyway I'm
incredibly inspired in the out to be
able to serve all of y'all and I think
everyone I speak for everyone on our
Khan Academy team all of the thousands
of volunteers and and the many people
who've donated light like yourselves so
I'm sad another one Instagram this one
Mooji asks how is Khan Academy planning
to help AP students study for
9 AP exams actually we're working on
getting College Board to join you in
this homeroom and and some folks
internally as well ya know that's a very
relevant question for those of you who
don't know
you know the AP which are these advanced
placement tests in the United States and
some parts of the rest of the world
these are essentially advanced high
school or intro college level classes
that are taken at high school level and
at the end of the year you traditionally
have something called an AP exam and
depending how a student scores from one
to five they could get various levels of
college credit depending on where they
where they go to college and this year
testing globally has become difficult
because it's not clear that school will
be in session during the test AP test or
normally April timeframe late April or
early May and obviously other forms of
tests are also a lot of question marks
so the College Board has announced that
they're going to do an online version of
the AP which is going to be different
from previous years and what we are
doing is we are coordinating we're close
friends with the College Board that's
another not-for-profit they're the folks
who administer the SAT and the AP exams
Khan Academy has always had we've the
official practice partner around the SAT
but we also have a lot of AP content
around calculus statistics biology
chemistry physics microeconomics
macroeconomics American history
APCs principles and civics in government
or American politics so what we're going
to do is continue to try to improve the
resources that we have and as we get
closer to the AP exam we're going to
think about partnering with College
Board to provide other ways so people
feel as prepared as possible what my
recommendation to any student who is
preparing especially if it's a subject
that we have the the resources for is
try to get as close to 90 or 100 percent
mastery on Khan Academy in that ap
subject in that AP course when I say
mastery you have as much practice as you
need on Khan Academy and you lards these
master mechanics that'll keep leveling
you up you can leverage course
challenges to just understand how well
you know the whole course at this point
you can use unit tests to break it down
by unit and then you can keep leveling
up with with the various mechanics and
then as you get closer to the ape
test what I recommend is we do have
worked example videos of the free
response and the best way to consume
those is start up the video look at the
prompt and then pause it and I usually
do say pause the video or one of our
contact creators say pause the video try
to enter it yourself and then let the
video play so you get that practice and
I think if you do those two things
you're going to be quite prepared and
we're gonna work with the College Board
to get more information out because I
know this this version of the AP is
going to be a little bit different than
what we've seen in the past so see other
questions we have so from Facebook I see
shala Karimi stes my fifth grade son is
a smart student but he doesn't challenge
himself at all he thinks he knows
everything how can I help him you know
I'm not an expert here and I hope in
future live streams we can bring in some
you know child psychologists or coaches
or whatever else my gut sense is you
know this all is about growth mindset
versus fixed mindset and there is some
research on how to help coach people to
eight towards a a growth mindset based
on your description description it
sounds like your son might be falling
into a fixed mindset now he think his
fixed mindset is I'm very capable I know
this stuff but even if your fixed
mindset is one of confidence that might
actually keep you from engaging in
things that you find difficult which it
sounds like might be happening here
because if you already have a self
perception that you're very protective
of that I'm capable then you might be
afraid to test that self perception and
so what I would do is work with your son
as much as possible to build a growth
mindset remind your son it's not about
some innate ability level it's how much
you're willing to push yourself out of
your comfort zone and your brain grows
the most when you push yourself out of
that comfort zone you struggle even fail
but you reflect on that failure and pick
yourself back up and history the world
however you want to define happiness
people who are able to or success people
who have a growth mindset
always pushing themselves who don't say
I'm smart or dumb but say hey I just
need to understand what I'm capable of
by keep pushing myself I embrace failure
they're going to be disproportionately
successful regardless of what your
definition of success actually is so
other questions from YouTube
Adithya asks what is your favorite book
that changed the way you think so
Adithya there's many many books that
have changed the way I think but
relative to what we've been talking
about at the Khan Academy mission I
think one of them is actually the
foundation series by a thick ass him off
that's more than one book but if I were
to pick one I would say just foundation
and actually I'm gonna give I'm gonna
give two books one is the foundation
series the foundation series I first
read it in middle school and what I
found inspiring about it was you know
it's the story it takes place thirty I'm
not giving away any of the plotline it
takes away it takes place thirty
thousand years in the future humanity
has colonized the galaxy there's a
Galactic Empire and there's this
professor named Harry Selden who sees
that and he studies a combination as a
new field of mathematics statistics
economics history and he's able to
statistically predict large-scale
historical movements and he sees with
his mathematics that the there's a large
probability that the Galactic Empire is
about to enter into a good dark ages the
dark ages that will last 10,000 years
and so he decides to do something about
it he wants and you know the dark ages
the Empire will get fragmented knowledge
will be lost you'll have war you'll have
famine and so he statistically sees that
if he's able to preserve the knowledge
of humanity in the periphery of the
galaxy someplace he his math shows him
that he will be able to shorten that
dark ages from 10,000 years to 1,000
years and and that's what the foundation
is it's it's the preservation of
knowledge and when I read that when I
was in Middle School there's a there was
a few takeaways I got from that it was a
bit of an AHA that if you really want to
preserve the essence of what makes a
civilization capable it really
knowledge and education and and if you
really want to help society the most
there's a lot of other things that
matter as well but knowledge and
education are at the root of it the
other thing that I found really
inspiring was this notion obviously it's
a science fiction book but this notion
of thinking far beyond your direct life
your direct generation or then your or
your direct benefit that as human beings
we sometimes need to think on a larger
scale and on a longer time scale and
obviously Harry Selden in the book is
thinking on a thousands of years time
scale and so when Khan Academy started
becoming I guess you could say a thing I
started tutoring family members and one
thing led to another and many of you all
started using it you know there was a
world where Khan Academy could have just
become an interesting YouTube channel
there is a world where we could have
just become a software company in EdTech
company but there's a world where we
would think about it a little bit more
like Harry Selden and this was
delusional for a guy operating out of a
walk-in closet not too long ago 10 years
ago but what if it could be a foundation
for the world what if it could be an
institution for the world that can help
billions of people tap into their
potential for generations and so that
has directly impacted my hopes my
aspirations for what Khan Academy can be
and and should be and you know this type
of crisis pinpoints it because we're
going through a global crisis right now
there's one point four billion students
around the world who normally would be
in school but are now not and this thing
we're creating Khan Academy has a role
to play so we're already starting to
hopefully help out a bit and then you
could imagine in 50 years a hundred
years well beyond you know my lifespan I
hope that in a hundred years 200 years
people would have would have trouble
imagining what the world was like before
everyone had free access to things like
this that I hope they take it for
granted than anyone regardless of where
you grew up you're going to be able to
have a lifeline and tap into your
potential and have access to opportunity
so there's other questions here so one
from Instagram someone says how do you
earn money this is a reef a gherkin on
Instagram
and so the simple answer is and I've
talked about it at different live
streams Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
organization which means no one owns
Khan Academy I don't own it or you own
as much of it as I do it's a public
charity but all of us who work at Khan
Academy we do get salaries and then that
sout those salaries come from the
donations so when folks donate to Khan
Academy some of it goes to our server
costs which are even before the crisis
we're running at around 6 or 7 million a
year our traffic is about 2.5 times that
so we could see you know 1015 million
dollars a year server costs or more and
then a lot of our budget is paying the
salaries of the engineers the designers
the product managers the content
creators the folks working with
classrooms and districts the folks
running the webinar to pay all of their
salaries so that we can create this
platform that that you know now we're
seeing you know tens many tens of
millions of students you know tens of
millions we're using it before and now
it's it's it's increasing dramatically
so other subject other questions and
danfield I'm just picking you know
randomly from this so actually I like
this question Facebook agra mafia asks
how can i help my community during these
times you know i was talking to my wife
about it and you know even my mom i'm
you know i'm kind of worried about her
she's by herself in new orleans and
obviously she's she's of a higher-risk
age and you know frankly just the
loneliness of you know not just living
alone but now being socially distanced
but then she has to worry about how she
going to get her groceries and things
like that and so I think one potential
idea especially for you younger folk who
have a lower risk and but even then you
should take extreme precaution is you
know find especially senior citizens in
your community who might need help
getting the groceries or things like
that and doing it for them you know just
as a service and you know still take all
the precautions make sure you have you
know try to wear masks whatever you can
do to minimize your own exposure but if
if your family has the means you can do
it you can buy the groceries and just
leave it on their porch or if the senior
has the means but it's just
highly risky for them to go out you know
for some find some way that they can
provide the funds but then you can go do
the grocery so it's a very tactical very
simple thing but I think it's very
powerful I think there's another layer
which is make sure that the people in
your community feel connected in this
time of social distanced obviously
people are worried about the virus but
the next worry is people are feeling
very lonely right now and so I think
especially with a lot of these seniors
but I would say anyone in your community
make sure everyone feels somewhat
connected so that might be getting on a
videoconference with them just talking
to them about life there's ways that we
can connect with each other and support
each other where we don't have to be in
person yeah so those are those are two
of my ideas there's other ideas you know
I know in a lot of places the blood
banks are running low because of it so
if you're young and you're you can do it
in a safe way that's an interesting
thing so there's I'm sure many many
other opportunities to to volunteer so
we have a question from the curious
student from YouTube I believe you're
the best teacher but who do you think is
or has been the best teacher to the
world well well thank you for that kind
of remark it makes me III think you know
there's III will never make a
superlative comment in almost any domain
especially something like teaching I
think there's different types of
teaching and there's and different
people are going to resonate with with
different folks you know I like to
believe and thank you for your
compliment that the things that I create
or the things that our team here at Khan
Academy creates resonate with as many
people as possible that help motivate
them help them learn but you know the
work that teachers do day in day out
goes far beyond that you know that's the
work of you know working with individual
students individual classrooms making
sure they're motivated you know a
diagnosing an individual student that
okay it might be this academic gap or
there maybe there's something at home
that I can help them with and so the
really amazing teachers I know are the
ones that really form those connections
and you know when I think about my own
childhood
or education I had many many amazing
teachers I was very blessed that way and
grew up in in in Louisiana and and the
but you know many teachers almost every
year I can name at least one but you
know in high school I had teachers like
Miss Kennedy and mr. Hernandez and they
were incredible teachers of their
subject area but what I really remember
is they they were they were very
connected to all of us students in a
very open way they they treated us you
know they put constraints on us as they
should have but they also they treated
us like peers I remember mrs. Kennedy
was our journalism mentor and and so
that modeled a lot of you know what I
try to emulate now in Khan Academy that
Khan Academy should never feel like
where the teacher you're the student
it's really that you know we're just two
human beings trying to help each other
and maybe right now we have a little bit
more knowledge and you might be the
recipient of it but it is a little bit
more of an equal thing you know mr.
Hernandez was my algebra 2 teacher and
then he was the mentor for several clubs
that I was in if I go back to middle
school I remember Miss North you know
she used to run her and I remember miss
Ellis in fifth grade they both used to
run their their English classes like
like university seminars and I remember
that was really fascinating and it
informs a lot of what we now recommend
for what the best model is when folks
get together yes use a Khan Academy if
you need lectures at your own pace use a
Khan Academy to get practice and
feedback and to get some of your
foundations and then ideally that can
free up class time to run it the way
that miss Kennedy or Miss North or miss
Ellis ran their classes which is more
dialog more simulations more games that
really push that higher-order thinking
so anyway there's a lot of layers to
what makes something a great teacher and
a lot of different types of teachers but
but thank you for the compliment so
there's one question that I'm actually
intrigued by no one's ever asked this
before this is from autumn again asking
Khan Academy should provide resources
for college essays so we don't have
resources for college essays yet or we
don't even have plans for that yet we do
have some resources on college
admissions if you do college admissions
Khan Academy do a Google search you'll
find it but my advice for folks writing
college essays is just be authentic just
be yourself
I think sometimes folks get so stressed
about things that they try to optimize
it so it's perfect in some way but when
you try to optimize it's perfect you're
not letting your true self out you're
not letting your vulnerability out and
you know I've talked to many of our
advisers or actually heads of admissions
departments that something you know
fairly selective universities and they
tell me you know you can't
how many kids just kind of fit a certain
pattern and they're just trying to have
this perfect essay but the ones that
really appeal to them are the ones where
when they read it they're like oh I see
the student I see the person behind this
this person is quirky this person's
authentic this person's honest and those
are the folks once again and they have a
growth mindset too they're not trying to
make their life look perfect they're
willing to admit their failures and
they're owning their failures those are
the students that they like to bring to
their community those are the students
that they think are going to be able to
do amazing things in the future so
that's my my best advice is just be as
authentic as possible in your essays
introspect who you are don't try to be
you know some ideal that you think other
people want you to be and frankly that's
life not just for that's the advice not
just for college essays but probably for
life so we have a question on Facebook
from Scott yang yes Sal this is on the
minds of lots of students our students
have to restart their courses because of
the school closures so I think that is
it's a very fluid situation what we've
seen in various districts I would be I
would be shocked if you have to restart
your courses like if you were taking
high school biology this year then all
of a sudden you're gonna have to retake
high school biology next year I don't
think anyone is you know in the
districts that we've been talking to
suggesting that type of thing I think
what will happen I know some of our the
local districts out here in California
they've kind of moved to a bit of a
pass/fail system so at least you get
credit
I think what we're going to have going
into the end of the school year
over the summer and the early next
school year is I think teachers schools
districts are going to be very open and
colleges are going to be college
admissions are going to be open to
alternative evidence that you mastered
the subject I don't know what these are
fully going to be I do you know think
that if you are able to master something
on Khan Academy and print it out and you
know sign a you know promise you know
that it's your work on an honor code and
it should really be your work that that
even that might carry weight because
people are looking for alternative
measures in this next year and I think
everyone is trying to err on the side of
doing right by everyone versus trying to
be punitive but I think that's a two-way
street everyone you know if you're the
student it's on you to be you know
authentic and honest and of your true
state and not try to game whatever a
system that gets put in place over the
next few months but I I wouldn't feel
anxious about having to completely
repeat it
I think there's ways that you can show
that you have that knowledge and that if
you're if you're good at marketing it so
to speak you will be able to to to do
fine I you know when I go back think of
even my own high school experience
obviously I didn't go through what we're
all going through right now but there is
a certain power to self-advocacy so I
remember I wanted to take some advanced
courses at the University of New Orleans
when I was 15 or 16 and I remember
walking in there you know 14 or 15 year
old and they're like who are you I'm
like I'm the high school kid I go to you
know grace King high school it's about
four miles away I'd love to take you
know multivariable calculus they're like
we don't offer that to you but I'm like
no I'm ready and they're like well how
do we know you're ready and then I had
to self-advocate I'm like give me a test
here's this and I obviously didn't have
Khan Academy back then and I think if
you advocate for yourself you'll also
people will will appreciate that
so I think that's another way to think
about it
so we have more questions here is so
from Instagram this is a question we've
gotten several time what's the best way
to avoid procrastination and I don't
want to pretend that I'm immune to
procrastination I've done my my fair
share and I think especially in the
context we're in where the news is it
kind of sucks you in it's very easy to
convince you so let me just spend five
minutes looking at what's going on in
the world and then that can turn into
longer than five minutes what what I try
to do actually one thing and I try to
limit how much I I look at the news
these days I want to be informed but I
don't want to be sucked into it I think
the other thing is and this is during
this crisis or pre this crisis just
always have a some structure and have a
bit of a checklist and then you can
build that momentum during the day I've
talked in multiple live streams I like
to wake my bed first in the morning I'd
like to do a meditation first thing in
the morning I always get ready first
thing in the morning even if I have
nowhere to go
even if it's a weekend I try to do a
little bit of exercise and that those
early wins helped me build momentum into
the day and once I get into the office
or in now the new world when I just
start working from home I try to okay
what are some things that I can I can
get some wins on the other thing and
this is the Pomodoro Technique that
we've talked about which is try to give
yourself some windows to work and then
make sure you take breaks as well so you
don't get burned out and what Philippe
is showing you is we've actually made
some meditations to help you stop
procrastinating and these are
meditations just a kind of a way to be
reflective of your own thoughts but you
know the gist of the the meditation the
procrastination one is you know don't
let your brain convince you because it's
oftentimes the fixed mindset in your
brain that is a fait afraid to get
started it's afraid to get started
because it might discover that it's
harder than you thought or you might not
finish it in time and that somewhat
self-destructively that fear keeps you
from starting and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy it does become
harder the key is ed that thought
process and say no I don't care what
you're trying to convince me brain
thoughts I am just gonna start I am just
going to put one foot in front of the
other start and see what happens
and if you do that then it kind of
breaks that procrastination circuit in
your brain and then as soon as you start
most times you're like oh this isn't so
bad this is kind of fun well why did I
procrastinate it so much but that's
that's you know there's other games you
can play with yourself or if you have a
due date on something just you know tell
yourself off the due dates earlier we
could we could talk about that but I'd
love any ideas you all have as well it's
not like anyone has solved
procrastination but we have ways of
dealing with it or minimizing it let's
see there's a bunch of questions here we
have some from Facebook I'm not chima
says what do you think about new
programs in the near future that could
impact a few next few generations
well I it's a fun question to think
about you know in the education realm
obviously I hope Khan Academy is in a
position that we can help billions of
folks for generations to come and
there's things that I hope we can layer
on I hope one day Khan Academy
you know we some ones the question about
credit or having to repeat classes
allude to something that I hope Khan
Academy can play a role in in the future
which is help people connect the
learning on Khan Academy so that they
get opportunity in the world or they get
credit so you know there's a lot of
things that we could do on on the Khan
Academy layer I think the other really
interesting things that are going on in
the in the world right and obviously
we're in the midst of a healthcare
crisis but I think in healthcare you're
going to have you know there's CRISPR
technology where we're gonna be able to
start literally editing DNA there's some
scary aspects to that we were in the
position to edit our genome but there's
there could be some very positive
powerful things from that as well I'm
inspired by some of the things that
might be happening in in in in
communications obviously the fact that
we can do this type of communication
right now without a ton of planning you
know in this time of crisis can you know
it's making the world whole world a lot
more connected I'm inspired by some of
the things that might be happening in
energy you know we're all worried about
what might happen in the climate and
whatnot but there's there are some
silver
linings there's you know people working
on nuclear power plants that might not
have any nuclear waste to them or
radioactive waste to them solutions like
that I think are pretty inspiring I'm
also inspired by you know new models of
Transportation people are talking about
ways to you know flying Carson and
whatever else and they actually seem
more real than not obviously space
travel reusable rockets satellite
networks that can give everyone
broadband and connectivity like we have
around the globe I think all of these
are going to be incredibly
transformational and they all in fact
affect each other and you know they
actually all would have impact on what
Khan Academy is as well so let's see
there's other questions here so some
from YouTube Susanna
Dominguez asked what is your favorite
part of Khan Academy well you know
that's like asking who's my favorite
child a favorite I will say what I think
is the most powerful part of Khan
Academy you know a lot of people
associate Khan Academy with videos and
we are proud of our videos and videos
are an important part of what we do but
I would say the most powerful part of
Khan Academy is the practice and
assessment exercise platform that we
have where students can get functionally
unlimited practice immediate feedback
there's Mechanics for them to progress
at their own pace and then all of that
ideally works when teachers are able to
look at their teacher dashboards or
parents are able to look at either the
parent or the teacher dashboard to help
unstick students and then to open up
what can happen in class time to be a
more higher higher order so I think
that's my that's what I think is a real
power of Khan Academy the the the it's
nice to get these micro explanations if
you're stuck but the real learning
happens when you try exercises you you
get feedback especially when you get it
wrong and then you reflect you look at
the step by step solution in the hints
and you're like oh and then you keep
trying and then you see it in a context
switching mode on a unit test or
something like that so we are at time
y'all asked you got me on me on my
soapbox on some of my team favorite
questions of like work at this baby and
thousands of years
but but thank you everyone for joining I
know this is an incredibly hard time for
the world I would say just as one human
being to to another human being the
silver lining of that is that we're all
in this together this is a shared
experience I remind myself that and
whenever I'm feeling a little isolated
and socially distanced and I remind
myself that I'm in a much more fortunate
situation than many many folks in the
world are finding themselves so we're
all on this together and I think we're
going to get through this together
and you know take care of yourself stay
healthy stay safe and all of us here at
Khan Academy are going to do whatever we
can to support you and please on future
live streams come on give us tips
feedback ideas for how we can do that
better thank you
you